[Applause]
Yeah yeah
me
uh
Club me
[Music]
[Applause] It's so
peaceful
[Music] A
normal life, nothing
special
37 years old with a
decent salary and nothing to worry about
It's no good, I'm a little late So
let's talk Nice to meet you. I'm Miho
Saruwatari.
I'm just being teased by Niibo, so please keep it to that, seniors
.
I've prepared something that I like
Well done It's scary It's close
It's too hot
I want
you to relate Confirmed
Successfully acquired a large number of heat resistance
I won't die from being stabbed
Confirmed Successfully acquired a large number
Continue Physical attack posture confirmed
Successful
Fuchu Nakayama I want to say it quickly
Shiga unconfirmed  Succeeded Acquire the sense of pain
Create a body that does not need blood
Succeeded just now-
Noisy Damer-
Only obtained at Kusu double
Yes 6
Number of trunk
acquisitions Successful By acquiring heat resistance  My skill has changed to the heat fluctuation system
God or
damner hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha
The contents of the hard disk of my PC at home
Soak it in the bath and completely erase it
[Music]
Data erase by electric current Failed due to lack of information
Raikou  As a measure, I acquired resistance to all dragons.
Do it,
computer
, I
begged you, you're going to die as a virgin
Reborn eunuch attack 4 a
I ate
so much I bought a unique ski direct shot I
manufactured it If I was a
30-year-old virgin and a wizard,
I would soon be in power, but it
's not a great sage's dream.
I will give you a unique skill to evolve into a great sage
Successful I
can't wait It's time to be quiet Haa super sa ah ah [music] I can't see anything
Where is this?
I
'm afraid I
'm late, it's okay It's not hotel time yet
I'm cool, so when I leaked a collab with elementary school students, it's black.
Chloe
Mego I can't see anything but I ca
n't feel the teaching When I can't feel
it
My
voice
doesn't come out
, and when I was in the middle of the day, Mr. Lou
What's going on with
me?
I
want to say what's going on?
Hey, you
can admit it
, but you're a slime, aren't you? Baan, you
're not human.
[music]
So why are you eating grass
?  The
poop stone is
put in the unique skill Predator's stomach.
This voice was heard when I was stabbed
.
It became possible to do it
quickly.
Predatory
body Eat the target and take it into the body and analyze it.You
can learn the skill of that target.When the
analysis is completed, mimicry is also possible.
It's also
possible to do that.
Valuable medicinal herbs that only grow in places
Raw materials for healing medicine
Masato interferes with this world Surreal special
2 It is a
substance that is the source of life for monsters
Life force I see, it is full of looting and valuable  Does that mean that there are a lot of medicinal herbs growing?
One day, I finished my palm
reading, and at the same time, I was frantically preparing medicine in my stomach, just in case there was an emergency.
If it's a rare medicinal herb like that, then this place is also
valuable, and
magic stones, which are places with high concentration, take in the corpses that have taken a long time to take in and corpse
unnaturally
.  Music]
Hmm, well, the achievements are also good
I ate magic ores wh
[music]
Um,
maybe I fell into the water
Lake
Slime doesn't float, does it
die this time?
I don't think so But what should I do?
Rhythmic gymnastics winning rate is 10%
Unique skill self-regeneration has been activated Even
if there is no pain, is there damage
?  What is it?
I don't have a mouth, so I can't speak.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Let's do it,
but there's an upper limit, but
what do you think?
Actually, I was sealed here 300 years ago
.  No, I
can't use it.
I can see when I sense a skill related to the surroundings.
It
's a skill that's an order of magnitude more powerful than a normal skill
Would you like to use Magic Perception?
Music]
[Music]
Let me introduce myself again My name is Crosswind Yubel Mudwind
Game There are only four dragons like this, all of them are one geeni Ah ah ah
Mach
Hey, you remember your promise, don't you?
I can't say that I didn't draw a bow.In
fact, it's a rare and
painful original technique
.
I used to be a human, but
when I was stabbed to death, when I realized it, I was like this
.
As far as I know, it's the first time it's
just fun.  I can't stand it, so it's
not a question of the people who came over from another
world.
Hmm, I see, I guess that's my skill
too. Maybe there are Japanese people too
.  Okay, it's
good to take it slow
Dora-san, who's out at 8, said that the instrument was sealed, wasn't she
?  It's
okay if you came to subdue me
like that.It's like Taro licking the opponent a little
, but it's not good.
Were you strong? Eh, it's
called a human hero who received a Calm, like 2. A human hero.
It's like a game
.
Is the glowing thing an infinite prison?
I'm
reading from another world.It's a
world that's deceiving.It's expected to play a role as a powerful game-like weapon.It's a
smooth socal.The
summoner uses magic to curse the soul so that it can't go against the Shinto priest.  I found out
what a terrible story it is. In
the world of hero ika mode, the head is weak in this world, and the teaching profession is definitely a scene skill.
I
've been without a lover for 37 years, and I've been pretty lonely How long have you been alone for 300 years
?  It's
a bad decision, it's a bad decision that wo
n't come again It
's so bad that all your friends ride and make you feel at night Hey,
it's a character
Mu
This is how I got stabbed by a passerby and died, reincarnated as a slime, and became friends with the stormy
Veldora.
Even beauty prevails
Tamura I wonder if he erased the card disk
I wonder if he didn't have anything before the kiss I
'm here
toranoana Senpai, please rest in peace
If the child was born and it was a boy
Problematic gathering river
ana
[music]
[applause] It's
disgusting Hope spreads so much amaran
[music]
Dreams are also tongues because it becomes rime no 9 y Hanging and increasing
me
street catches good beep
ni
uh
still
ni
[music]
amaran
nan
ni
aname
nani
[music]
dee
Next meeting with goblins